- He's a Hong Kong business magnate,
investor,
and philanthropist.
- According to Bloomberg,
he's the richest person in Asia.
He was listed by Forbes
of having a fortune
of over $34 billion.
- He's Li Ka Shing,
and here are his top
ten rules for success.
(speaking in Chinese)
(soft classical music)
(soft Chinese music)
- Thank you so much for watching us.
We made this video because
Wei Yung asked us to.
If you'd like to see someone else
to be profiled,
please let us know
in the comments
and we'll see what we can do.
- We'd also like to know which one of
Li Ka Shing's Top Ten Rules
meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments below
and we'll join the discussion.
- Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.